when when you're when when all is said
and done i would love it if someone
sat down with you and and made maybe a
book of all the things that cost taught
you
now i don't know all those things that
chris told me and nowadays would not be
cool you know what i don't know um cuss
was born in 1908
in 1908 they had a different opinion of
people having opinions like women and
stuff like that
and it's because
believing that he cares for the
downtrodden people
and this and that's for the blacks and
latinos and
irish people who are being
abused by the irish people of that time
which is crazy
um he really um
he really was that guy he was the guy
that fought for the people that
that didn't have um anyone to fight for
them
he was just that guy he wanted to be
that person he wanted to be a person
that people looked up to and he was the
boss and stuff he was he just wanted to
be a people
and when i read his book and i ran
around at the bottom he was successful
his whole life
he was always the guy in the
neighborhood that people came through to
settle beasts and talk
things over with and loan people stuff
and help people out
and he liked being in that position of
being able to teach people something
what he believed was teaching them
something
he knew so much about the human mind
well he's well when he died this is very
interesting
we were dying in the camille there was
um
that i lived with him in camille and she
weakened i was cleaning the room and
when i saw in this room i saw all books
about psychiatry and the mind and
everything and mystic stuff and all that
stuff
and i said this is what he was really
about um
yeah he just like he believed his mystic
believer as well he believed in
zen and art of archery and all that he
had those books and he was just a
believer
and more than what we saw yeah you know
it was more than what we
could physically articulate going on
with us
as human beings or what we are called
when you sit back and you think about
your career and how fortunate you were
to run into that guy
i mean how much did that play a a a part
in your mind like when you knocked out
trevor berbick
became the youngest ever heavyweight
champion when you're thinking about that
we
did you ever stop and think like man how
lucky am i that i ran into that man
no no he said he summons me he summoned
you
whoa
makes sense i mean you think about a man
whose life work
involved psychiatry involved the mind
boxing hypnosis
training all these boxers floyd
patterson had all these great fighters
and then he wants one great one
before it's over no no he wants an
animal
i'm an animal
he summoned you
what did that feel like for you does it
make sense
no i believe what he told me yeah
it it i mean i don't know if i believe
you could summon someone
but god damn that seems like it's real
yeah
that seems like it's real i don't know i
think you could do whatever you believe
you can do
if you really believe it yeah well that
that was what i got out of all the
things that i read about you and him
together and
being able to talk to you about you and
him is that he
he gave you these tools to understand
the way your mind worked and you just
ran with them
um i'm an extreme kind of person yeah so
i get carried away
if if your confidence is not at um
a delusional perspective you have the
right confidence
yeah you get so amped up mike you even
even he's sitting here talking to you
about these things i could see it in you
you get amped up even just talking about
achieving things
talking about success talking about the
mind you know i could see it inside of
you you get very fired up about these
things
yeah um i have to be serious about
anything
i want to accomplish yeah that
intensity is what made you special i
mean that
that i'm